Hey, what do I do when you know, I've got somebody on trial and
The leads are slow
You know, the leads are a little bit slower than I thought. What do I do? Okay guys just set the proper expectations
What when I get on I say hey look
I'm gonna send you a couple more leads and I always say this I say for these first couple they I want to get you
Really juicy leads. So I'm not gonna send you any of the the rinky-dink stuff
So it might be a little bit inconsistent. You might get one today one in a couple days, you know
You might get two in a day
It's gonna be a little bit hit and miss but I want to make sure to get you really nice jobs
So just just a heads up in case you get one from me and then you don't hear from me for a couple days
That's why okay. That's all you got to say that problem solved